well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look then at what
is on the front pages time to see what
is making the headlines with the daily
mails consultant editor andrew pearce
and the broadcaster and former mp anna
subri great to see both of you uh
staying with us until just before
midnight so front pages then let's start
with the financial times reporting that
in cooperation with the bank of england
the chancellor rishi sunak will announce
a package of measures tomorrow aimed at
curbing inflation and diverting a cost
of living crisis
the telegraph describes mr sunak as
splashing out on the multi-billion pound
package
and the daily mail said that the heat is
now on the chancellor with bills to rise
by 650 pounds millions of families to
receive cuts in council tax that's
according to the times the yorkshire
post meanwhile quotes a minister from
huddersfield who calls the government's
leveling up proposals a master plan to
radically improve the uk
but the eye speaks to oh excuse me the
eye speaks to sources who believe it
hasn't been properly funded and lacks
ambition
the guardian has word of three more
conservative mps submitting letters of
no confidence in the prime minister
the metro proclaims putin gives boris a
buzz remarking on the phone call held
between the two leaders and the fact raf
jets were scrambled today to intercept
russian military aircraft in uk airspace
the express follows suit stating raf
jets scramble to nudge out russian
bombers and warning mr putin against
taking what he calls a tragic gamble
while the star has president putin
sending extra troops to russia in what
the star describes as squeaky bomb time
one reminder that by scanning the qr
code that you'll see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and listen to our guests so
let's bring them in andrew pearce and
anna subre welcome to both of you um big
day tomorrow anna uh daily mail and a
number of the newspapers reflecting on
energy bills due to go up explain what
happens and what the issue is
so the cap is coming up off rather and
it means that around about april then
energy bills are going to
absolutely go through the roof they're
going to soar they're going to go up
doubling um to 500 the daily mail says
650 pounds and that obviously is an
awful lot of money at a time when we
know that inflation is set to go up to
seven percent uh we know that of course
this national insurance increase
increases coming in as well so it's
going to be really tough on working
families and so rishi sunang's big
moment is coming i think it's a real
test for him
it's going to be we're going to see is
rishi sunak going to do what he did with
the furlough scheme and actually put out
a real helping hand to people so it's
it's dominating i think so all the front
pages you've got it there in the ft
uh and they're talking in the fb about
this sort of the bank of england putting
up interest rates as well
going up from 0.25
to 0.05
so there's a rise there
um and as i say it's on all the papers
and it's going to be hard for families
and it's going to be a real test i think
of whether rishi soon act can come up
with something that pleases members of
the public frankly ordinary folk
and therefore pleases mps
increasing his threat to boris johnson
whether he actually is seen as a
credible alternative to him but but
mostly and more importantly for you know
really frankly for ordinary folk is what
does this mean for their energy uh bills
and
there will be a bit more about it but
something's going to happen because it's
a this is a serious real really going to
hit people's pockets hard as well yes
and and the ft as you said focusing on
actually increasing interest rates to
reduce inflation something that in the
past you know you'd have massively high
interest rates but clearly the mood's
not not there yet
a range of things have been mooted
haven't they for the government to
tackle this uh andrew what is what's the
ideas coalescing around in the in the
papers what are we likely to hear
well one idea is that the treasury
provide loans to the energy companies
who will then pass it on immediately to
consumers in a rebate on their energy
bills are cutting their energy bills the
government will claw that money back at
some point when the energy price
stabilizes rust gas prices have gone
through the roof for a number of factors
uh coming out of uh covered all around
the world also the the the fun and games
that uh putin is playing with the
russian with the gas price uh as well
and they're also talking about um a
cutting council tax for poorer families
that's something we hadn't heard of
until the last 24 hours that's quite
interesting that would help that would
be aimed particularly at poorer families
and there's still of course the idea of
will they cut the the vat on fuel bills
now on domestic bills that's five
percent they can do that now because
we've left the european union but vat on
commercial uh fuel business often as
high as 20
now that will often be passed on to the
customer in whatever form which is going
to add to inflationary pressures so we
wonder whether the chancellor will look
at that he's going to make a statement
in the commons tomorrow it'll also be a
televised press conference as well and
anna's right to raise about what this
does to she soon outstanding because um
polls suggest he's the most popular
politician in britain today
but if you look at the conservative home
league table which is what tory party
members think he's been falling down and
down and down uh which will concern him
because there could be conservative
leadership contest within the next six
months to a year who knows and he was
seen as the front runner and of course
it was easy to be popular when he was
giving money away through the furlough
scheme now the cost of living crisis is
kicking in he's not as popular so this
could be a this is a very big political
test for him but um the real test is
what he does for families who but no
fault of their own are going to find
their electric and gas bills going up to
nearly 2 000 pounds a year a rise of 650
pounds which is too much it's it's
eye-watering and it will put families in
real fuel poverty there'll be families
choosing between feeding themselves and
keeping and whether they can afford to
turn the gas on which is why the chance
has got to come up with something pretty
good tomorrow and suggestions of years
of high gas prices which is part of the
part of the issue especially with the
ukraine russia issue on the back burner
as well but the the other context of
this is uh the leveling up agenda
yorkshire post master plan to radically
improve uk the leveling up papers
pledges on mayors and inequality but
doubts over funding um you know is there
a thumbs up at least um from the
yorkshire post uh for this and what do
you make of what you heard today anna
yeah i mean as you think as you'd expect
because it's the yorkshire post then
there's there is a gentle welcoming of
what michael gove has set out but i i
think there's also within the yorkshire
post and obviously you see it in the eye
i think it is in a number of other
papers you'll you'll see that
the real concern is actually there is no
new money at all so if you've got no
more funding a lot of this is just words
on a piece of paper and and you know do
they admirable aims i mean there is a
there's a fair criticism that you know
we have had 12 years of conservative
government and it's almost an indictment
on the failings of 12 years off that
government but moving on from that i
think the other criticism that we're
seeing coming out of it from some of the
mayors as well in some of the papers is
that actually whilst people like andy
street over in the west midlands and
then andy burnham up in the northwest
now the two mayors have done extremely
well but actually their argument is we
need more powers what michael gove said
today was
we're going to have more of these
directly elected mayors but my concern i
think others have the concern that one
they've got to have real powers and also
you've frankly got to get the caliber of
people locally like burnham and like
stream
the the eye also talks about no more
funding to level up the uk to be fair
the chief secretary to the treasury
simon clark who spoke to us this
afternoon
said that we invested an enormous amount
in fact a record amount of the budget in
the spending review last autumn
some 150 billion pounds more of total
departmental spending this is the most
any parliament this century and all the
white paper is doing today is providing
a framework for that money so the no new
money issue as far as he's concerned was
dealt with last autumn but um i don't
know how that sits with you
andrew well well he i mean i heard
michael gove saying much the same too
the money was announced then i think
this is really ambitious and bold and we
should really welcome it because it's
not about just 12 years of touring
neglect michael gove would accept that
uh it's about 60 years of neglect of
some of our northern and midland towns
they've just been forgotten there has
been a definite shift towards giving
more money to the southeast more
resources to the south east we have got
some of the biggest regional uh
disparities in income educational
achievement life expectancy in this
country than anywhere else in europe
that didn't happen in the last 12 years
that's been going on since the second
world war and it's about time the
government tried to put a stop to it and
i think this is an ambitious attempt and
we're going to see more elect directly
elected mayors good because i think
they've been doing a pretty good job uh
and um and there and also gov has
changed a role a bizarre role he said he
inherited uh which means since 2015 one
and a half billion pounds of regional
aid has gone to the southeast and only
150 million to the north he's ripping up
these regulations though the money can
start moving backwards what he's got to
be careful though politically is some
people in what we used to call the blue
wall uh will be thinking uh is all the
money is everything going to go to the
north and the midlands what about the
south west there's
poverty in some of the parts of the
southwest and there are some poor parts
of the southeast too
and particularly in london so we've got
to remember that yeah no you make a good
point there i just want to share the mac
cartoon i read it the wrong way around
actually that north surrey was going to
call it call itself lancashire but i'm
wrong actually
which is the point you're making north
surrey formerly lancashire is part of
the leveling up strategy but as you said
we'll see which areas calls themselves
where at the end of that
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now andrew pearce
and anna subrie welcome back to both of
you um so to boris johnson we go andrew
front page of the guardian uh three more
tory mps um will there be more in the
wings do you think
potentially um what they need really
what's happening it's a trickle we i
think 14 mps have now declared
themselves that they've lodged submitted
letters to the chairman of the 22
committee seeking a confidence debate uh
there's talk it could be as many as 17
we don't really know because they don't
have to tell us they'd and i'd have to
say um the tory the tory parliamentary
party is one of the more duplicitous
electorates you might meet in this
country frankly uh but um one of the
people who's quite
maybe seen as a surprise is gary street
now he's been an mp since 1992 he's he's
a very proud staunch very proud of his
christian faith uh and he would be
offended by the fact um you could argue
that the prime minister was a little
economical with the truth about these
parties when he said there were no
parties and no rules and regulations
were broken well we know currently the
police are investigating 12.
okay and we've just got one minute left
i'm afraid um well you know you've been
there you've got the t-shirt your
thoughts
no i mean andrew's absolutely right gary
streeter really shocked me because he's
a thoroughly
sensible really it does things when he
really believes very strongly in them
he's you know he doesn't just send off a
letter without a lot of careful thought
and that is deeply deeply significant
but there's a hell of an operation being
launched by the great klingon boris
johnson and his cronies to keep him in
power i don't know how long he's going
to stay i think it's scandalous and i
think it's deeply regrettable that
conservative mps are saying so much in
private yet they haven't got the courage
to come out get rid of him get somebody
else and get up when we're doing the
work that should be done